The really great thing about femininity is that if you are a female,
you already have it deep within you.
It is in your DNA. It is in every part of you.
I'll get comments from women saying,
can you give me tips on how to be more feminine?
Because I've never been like that.
It's just not me. Again,
the truth is that you already are that.
But our current society does not praise or value femininity
in a lot of cases. And so
I think a lot of us grew up believing that we needed to act masculine
in order to be valued, in order to be respected.
And we kind of built this hard shell around ourselves.
So you just have to figure out how to shed off that layer.
I think the number one way is to nurture.
That really is the core and really is the essence of femininity.
If you can just find someone or something to take care of right now.
Today, I find that is when I feel my most feminine.
For a lot of women,
that is simply being more intentional about raising your children.
Really turn it into an art.
Having a morning routine, teaching them things,
snuggling them, being warm with them.
If you have a partner or a spouse,
you can really, again,
be more intentional about how you care for them.
Be the soft place to land when they come home from work
or whenever you get To see them.
And even if you don't have a significant other,
there are plenty of people and friends you can nurture.
Even nurture a pet, like,
even watering and caring for plants,
like that is nurturing.
And that is going to really bring out your femininity.
And that does not make us weak.
That is actually a very, very powerful strength that we have to take.
Humans and animals, make them feel safe and loved.
Mommy! What, baby?
Again, there are so many other things that you can do to kind of
feel more feminine, to shut off that masculinity that I, again,
society, I feel like,
has just incentivized us to have.
But I think the first step
and the biggest thing anybody can do right now today is to nurture.